regardez ce que je ne récupère et ici
regardez moi ce joli projet que j'ai
reçu c'est la nouvelle microsoft surface
duo c'est le retour de microsoft dans
l'univers du smartphone en retour très
attendu avec un produit que j'attendais
depuis un petit moment
je vous explique j'étais au mois
d'octobre 2010 9 à new york invité par
microsoft pour découvrir leurs nouvelles
gammes de produits dans cette nouvelle
gamme est bien une grande et belle
surprise c'est l'annnonce de 7 microsoft
surface duo est également de la
microsoft surface mais où
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant l'année autant stand by à
la duo qui est là qui est sorti qui est
sorti 18 donc ça c'est super le produit
les la javel or ce bar donc aujourd'hui
on va l'ouvrir on va le boxer on va
regarder si microsoft a réussi son
retour dans l'univers du smartphone avec
un produit hybride un produit à mi
chemin effectivement entre un smartphone
et un pc c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui
est réalisé en partenariat avec une
piquette une assurance 100% digitale
d'un nouveau genre king va assurer vos
produits tech mais pas uniquement
par exemple votre microsoft surface duo
qui coûte à peu près 1500 euros eh bien
ça serait dommage de prendre des risques
lorsque vous sortez et de ne pas la
protéger clic va vial assuré contre le
vol mais également pour les dégâts par
casse ou liquide dans la limite de haut
vol et de dommages par an les
inscriptions se font sur clint point fr
et ensuite vous pilotez tout dans votre
application de la signature du contrat
jusqu'à ratio des sinistres point
positif de clic c'est que vous native et
l'assurance que lorsque vous n'avez
réellement besoin par exemple vous
partez en vacances pendant les jours et
bien pendant dix jours peut-être que
votre microsoft surface duo restera dans
un placard rangé je ne sais pas en tout
cas ce moment là pouvaient venir
désactiver l'assurance et vous ne payez
pas pendant cette période mais si vous
l'utilisez pour sortir de chez vous pour
des rendez-vous ou autre et bien ce
moment-là vous voulez activer votre
assurance et vous ne payez en réalité
que lorsque vous l'activez si vous
arrive le moins de problème vous avez
180 centres de réparation agréé par clic
sur tout le territoire
les réparations ce forum général sous 24
heures et si ça traîne un petit peu et
bien on vous prêtera un smartphone de
valeur équivalente
et ça c'est vachement cool je vous ai
déjà parlé de cliquer dans une
précédente vidéo je vous ai mis le lien
en bas dans la description pour tout
savoir sur cette assurance d'un nouveau
genre vous pouvez assurer votre
smartphone mais bien plus que vos
smartphones notamment votre caste votre
vélo électrique votre tablette
et bien plus encore je vous renvoie aux
liens en bas d'un description pour
découvrir clic est assurée tous les
objets qui vous tiennent à coeur
c'est la partie prick est très différent
que propose microsoft ici par rapport à
d'autres produits à savoir qu'ici vous
avez deux écrans avec une charnière au
milieu qui se bouche de tous les côtés
on n'est donc pas dans l'idée d'un écran
pliable qu'on va retrouver sur le
samsung galaxy z folle de 2 ou encore
chez huawei sur le myhtique c'est cela
aussi c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
toute chose ça vous permet d'avoir
d'autres usages qu'on peut pas retrouver
avec les produits concurrents
la boîte déjà j'aime bien petit efficace
un plan dans les écriteaux microsoft duo
sur le côté on va avoir également
quelques informations ici on voit
qu'effectivement ici mais on a du
bluetooth 5.0 on voit qu'on a de
l'android 10ge pas si vous savez il ya
eu un prêt brief jour avec de la presse
ou un bris pour tout cas des médias et
dans lequel ils vous disaient la
charnière elle est assez dingue
justement envie de voir cette charnière
est assez dingue ou pas hier c'est un
peu un miroir on se voit vraiment
travers mais déjà j'aime bien
effectivement la charnière vous le
mettez comme vous voulez ça bouge pas ça
s'est super bien moi tout il surprend
tout de suite et qui sont vraiment mais
vraiment extrêmement impressionnant
c'est la fille laisse regarder ça la
finesse absolument incroyable je vends
mon iphone à côté c'est assez assez
assez surprenant orco cadiale évidemment
il est un peu moins loin que plus large
le format est super mais lorsque je peux
mettre dans la poche sans que cela pose
trop de problèmes
il est un peu large un peu long mais
sinon bon au niveau du format c'est très
compact ça ça me surprend je n'avais vu
je n'avais jamais pris en main donc là
elle fait le découvert comme ça c'est
vraiment super cool on peut le mettre
comme on veut on peut le mettre en mode
attente on peut venir le poser dans
l'autre sens pour se regarder un film
qu'est-ce qu'on a ensuite à l'intérieur
de cette boîte alors est en effet devoir
surface du au bumper qui est
spécialement conçu pour aider à protéger
votre appareil ok on a une petite
protection attaché le cerfeuil au bunker
à auquel j'ai pompé pas mal pas mal ici
je vais voir à quelques petits donne
quelques infos gilles agile pour votre
tiroir de cartes sim de la dore ok ça ne
va câble de charge et cie opus écouteurs
tout en us de ces fonds jai pas de prise
jack de très compliqué et j'ai retrouvé
ici avec mon bloc d'alimentation au
hockey ce corps sexy blake d'alim qui va
servir pour plusieurs pays à la fois je
pense moi ici j'ai la version fr
mais j'imagine qu'on peut très bien
avoir une version étrangère où on aime
glisser dedans tac en usb c'est
également avant qu'on commence vous
invite à laisser un joli poussé m dire
en commentaire qu'est ce que vous pensez
du retour de microsoft dans l'univers du
smartphone et qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ce format là est ce que vous trouvez
pertinents ou alors pas du tout mark et
moi samba en commentaire alors premier
truc que je vous embrasse mais
qu'effectivement j'ai plein de boutons
pour venir l'allumé qui situent juste là
il est juste ici mon bouton pour nuire à
l'allumer et pour l'éteindre et la gym
au capteur d'empreintes digitales dont
je pense le monde autrement que par des
empreintes digitales je dirais je la lui
directement peut venir l'allumé là mais
je suis obligé de passer pas comme ça
d'empreintes digitales pour rien
déverrouiller ça aurait été intéressant
qu'on l'a effectivement un seul et même
bouton qui fasse office de capteur
d'empreinte digitale et en même temps
deux boutons pour venir est allumée pour
l'éteindre ça fonctionne on le retrouve
dans d'autres smartphones mais c'est
vrai que comme on a un produit stor
technologies qui est intéressant sans
éthique ou de faire comme ça alors bon
bref passons un peu ce point de détail
déjà ce qu'on voit tout de suite c'est
qu'effectivement l'écran est d'assez la
cote un peu miroir mais vraiment
regardez là vous voyez la lumière après
les fortes lumières que j'ai pas un fond
d'écran qui va venir prêter un peu plus
que ça a changé
le papier peint à se mettre quelque
chose de clair je pense que ça sera
mieux voilà comme ça s'est beaucoup
mieux passé très très grande honte du
coup je vois vraiment tout ce que j'ai
de tous les côtés qu'est ce qu'on va
bien pouvoir faire communiquer sur le
playsport donc là je vois que j'ai mon
plat store ici alors j'ai vu que je
pouvais venir
je monte comme ça je peux le maître de
l'autre côté ils mettent là je vois
aussi que si je le mets line je m'arrête
au milieu je le mets en grand yes ça
c'est pas mal c'est un peu bizarre que
ça fait vraiment me le coupé comme ça à
la voyez le mot classe ment il me manque
un bout le mot recherche des
applications l'aï moment comme vous ça
c'est du point de détails de finition la
partie de la charnière au milieu est
considérée comme une partie de l'écran
intégré donc riz
ces affiches faudra vraiment venir voir
à l'usagé si ces problèmes éthiques ou
pas une fois de plus laissé moins peu de
temps venez vous abonner comme ça vous
saurez tout des comparera du test d'ici
quelques jours
ça ne saurait tarder on va regarder ça
très très vite je le prends je te le
mettre là si je veux hockey j'aime bien
ce côté pour rien naviguer ça ne dérange
pas de le sentir sous le doigt la voyez
pas ce qu'on pourrait se dire ah je le
sens où le doigt ce que ces
problématiques pas du tout ça marche et
donc là c'est pareil je te vire au vert
autre chose bon là et qu'il faudrait un
deuxième plextor donc voilà ça mousse
reach en fait dont je peux pas la même
chose je pense que si je fais ça j'ai
mis sur le ps store ça me change de côté
pourquoi pas c'est marrant donc
important et nous paye ce temps gelé la
up je vais vers le haut je l'enlève
ici donc je remets un pelé store par
exemple ici je mets spotify est ce que
je peux venir et à partir maintenant ça
me louvre ça ne ferme l'autre la partie
photo ça ça m'intéresse partie photo
bienvenue dans votre appareil photo
ok ça ça me va qu'est ce qu'ils ont à me
proposer au niveau de l'appareil photo
fait bois suivant prenez une photo
retourner pour changer l'affichage
capturer ok j'ai compris l'histoire donc
là je me vois sur cette caméra là j'ai
pas d'autres caméras
ah ça c'est ballot ça effectivement
c'est tout bête hein c'est sous mes yeux
je vois est dû le voir et ben non j'ai
pas de caméra à l'arrière ce qui est
joli ne pas avoir de caméra à l'arrière
mais par contre du coup j'ai qu'une
caméra de celle ci ah ouais ouais je
suis pas sûr là je suis vraiment pas sûr
ah ça je sais pas si c'est la bonne idée
en fait j'ai que ça en photo vidéo je
vais filmer qu'avec celle là l'aja tout
petit capteur qu'est ce que je vais
pouvoir faire avec ça au lol lol ah là
là là ça ça à mon avis c'est un point
qui est vraiment négatif qui va leur
coûter très très cher parce que quand on
sait aujourd'hui que l'usagé photo est
extrêmement important je sais que c'est
compliqué parce que quand on vient créer
un appareil photo si vous voulez on a
des couches au niveau de l'optique et
c'est pour ça que sur les smartphones
vous avez toujours la partie de
l'optique qui vient se détacher si vous
créez un fameux déséquilibre là pour
tout vous n'êtes pas de déséquilibre
s'est posé à plat donc s'il avait voulu
mettre une optique à l'arrière ils ont
été obligés de créer un déséquilibre et
s'ils créent un déséquilibre bien vous
ne peut pas bien l'utiliser comme ça
c'est juste une question de fabrication
ouais bah ouais ça ça pour moi ça
ça va être vraiment rédhibitoire pour
beaucoup d' usage ça c'est vraiment
dommage en fait on va dire qu'ici on a
une petite caméra de celle ci pour venir
faire qu'un peu sky pour venir discuter
unis à pouvoir intel et travailler avec
une petite qualité mais en fait vous
avez un smartphone avec absolument aucun
appareil photo et ça c'est dommage
vraiment faim pour l'usa jean paul ii
photo vous n'en avez pas donc on voit
qu'on est vraiment sur un produit en
fait dit ou bien produit plus
professionnel son usage pro que son
usage particulier ça va être compliqué
on est un peu près 1500 euros il n'est
pas destiné à tout le monde ça c'est une
évidence ça c'est vraiment vraiment
vraiment dommage parce que j'ai repéré
plusieurs points qui était un petit peu
déconnant là dessus le premier c'est
effectivement cette partie photo gm
vient de découvrir avec vous on va dire
que le deuxième c'est la partie du
processeur ici vous avez un sénat
dragonne 855 c'est à dire que c'est le
processeur de qualcomm de 2019
on se remet un peu dans l'histoire fin
2020 a été présenté le processeur pour
2020 talent pour cette année sa dette
aux dragons qui sont 88 fin 2019 a été
présenté le processeur pour 2020 sa
dragonne 865 et fin 2018 a été présenté
pour 2019 le snapdragon 855 que vous
retrouver ici dans cette bécane qui
vient de sortir en 2021 en france et qui
est sorti au mois d'août ce mois d'août
2020 aux us
donc on se retrouve avec un processeur
qui est deux générations passées et il
faut être plus un tarif d'un peu plus de
1500 euros
donc ça c'est problématique donc à ce
côté là que les problématiques en terme
de performance il ya le côté
effectivement de faits d'une parade
photo qui est problématique il ya le
fait que vous n'avez pas de 5 g ici vous
avez un smartphone mini ordinateur qui
est 4g qui n'est pas 5 g ça peut aussi
poser problème
et puis le dernier point c'est
effectivement cette partie coupée en
deux est-ce qu'elle va être vraiment
intéressante et notamment pour des
usages pensa instagram
alors je vais l'installer je vais tester
je vous dirais mais il faut vraiment
prendre le temps de le tester il ya
quand même quelques points qui sont qui
me font un peu peur on verra ça lors du
test
par contre en tout cas ce que je saluais
ce que j'aime bien c'est le format tout
petit petit petit ça j'adore tout ça
vraiment vraiment vraiment cool
la charnière elle est superbe le produit
vous avez plusieurs usages appuyé deux
fois pour changer d'écran donc là je le
mette ce côté là donc là je suis là ou
pas qu'est ce qui se passe je veux pas
je peux rien faire si le mais comme ça
j'ai les deux
et si je le mets comme ça j'arrive ici
et si j'arrive ici je peux rien faire
est là lui et est un bon il ya tout un
petit peu mystérieux à venir regarder
effectivement ne concentre pas dans
quelques jours au niveau du texte avant
de le dire vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette nouvelle ici microsoft
surface du logement la tente d'égaler là
je suis très forte par vous en parler on
va se parler d' usage on va regarder si
les points qu'on a relevé ici sont
vraiment bloquant est problématique
ou alors est ce qu'on arrive malgré toi
bien utilisé surtout si de comprendre ce
qui se passe est ce qu'un petit bug
c'est peut-être possible aussi les ce
qu'est une mise à jour je sais pas on va
approfondir c'est en tout cas
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire maintenant je trouve
très vite quand il ya par les textes des
bisous des coeurs et des groupes en
chocolat pour vous tous